et génial ma mère en fait je crois
qu'elle a aucun défaut elle oscille
toujours entre une très grande je
voulais voir quelque chose et un froid
glacial et oublie moi quelque chose qui
te fais mon vieux veut dire trois plots
bon 2 à 3 des cas et à périers charrier
va la chercher à des cayes à périers
j'arrive il parvient à limiter ma mère
un des cavaliers charrier ses gestes sa
manière de parler de finale
merci non le seul qui se fait jamais
prendre c'est mon père je t'avais en cas
de dognen maintenant je sais pas
pourquoi mais il ne veut pas que ce soit
une fille c'est quoi ce soir sa cape en
picardie ce week-end parce que je
l'attendais dans ta nouvelle pension
dans ma nouvelle pension ou cette
pension était merveilleuse
finaxo rencontré jane
en fait j'avais géré et pbgc y en a
plein qui vivent très heureux
la plainte de quoi donc n'a pas essayé
tu peux pas savoir j'ai toujours eu peur
des chevaux forcément on marché
vous devez porter de verenex l'anus mien
à la mesta cayenne
ça chante ma petite [ __ ] mais dites-moi
jeune homme vous prenez des médicaments
monga au moins t'es pas tous